violet is with us in Kansas City hi
violet how are you great how are you
doing
better than I deserve what's up hey so I
am just recently engaged and my fiance
he actually lives in Dominican Republic
so he doesn't have a lot of money it's
like a third world country I am 40 mm
and death and I I want to get married to
him but I'm just nervous because I know
I'm I'm one's like step number two of
paying off my debt doing the debt
snowball and I'm just wondering if it's
a good idea to get married knowing that
I will have student loans to pay less to
pay I don't mind folks getting married
in debt at all or having babies while
they're in debt at all none of that
there's a problem for me the only
problem is if you're not on the same
page that we're gonna kill the debt
we're gonna both work like maniacs to
cause that to happen so as he got a job
he did have a job as a mechanic and then
for some reason now he doesn't have it
anymore some reason that sounds kind of
thing yeah I mean explanation was that
their management got hired on new people
so now he doesn't have the job so that
was his explanation okay and how long
have you all been dating we've been
together for nine months and how old are
you I'm 23 and he is how old he's 22 and
he's from the Dominican Republic he
lives there he lives there yes really
[ __ ] where would you live were you
married so once we're married how the
process of him coming here right yes
okay and he was an auto mechanic in the
Dominican Republic
he's a mechanic on whatever like it I
was I'm not sure of like what he
specifically did so there's like some
language I'm learning Spanish I'm an
intermediate to fluency and he doesn't
know any English I know this sounds
weird but my understanding was that he
is just basically a mechanic I've seen
he I've seen
I'm going to work and all that stuff so
I'm not sure what he specifically worked
on how many times have you met him in
person four times okay I go back and
forth to travel over there right okay
all right um well here's some things I
don't mind you getting married and I
don't mind him coming here and he's
gonna get a job and you guys work
together and make a lot of money and pay
off the debt and live happily ever after
okay that's one option I am obligated
because of this show to tell people what
I would do if I were in your shoes I
have a 30 year old daughter and a 34
year old daughter and a 27 year old son
so I've got kids older than you okay
yeah that are all married and I've been
in the Papa Dave chair we call it quite
a bit over the years and so I'm gonna
change hats from financial guru to Papa
Dave and tell you a couple things that I
would tell you if you were my daughter
okay
okay number one it has been known to
happen
that folks who want to come to this
country will do anything to get to come
here and anything includes talking
someone and conning someone into
marrying them so I'm not saying that's
happening but that flag went up in my
head hearing this story so I want you to
just be careful be wise and be very
aware do not be a naive person who gets
taken advantage of and you call me back
later with a disaster please I don't
want pain to come to your life okay okay
so you lot watch for that number two
sometimes people from other cultures
will work rings around Americans their
work ethic is 10x of the typical
American sometimes from people with
other culture are hound dog in the Sun
lazy on the front porch don't work much
people I'm not hearing things I like in
your description of his job and his job
loss
I've seen pictures of him going to work
statements like that scare the crap out
of me as Papa Dave for my young daughter
I'm talking to okay yeah like I want
some as your as your surrogate dad here
for just a second I'm not but I'm just
speaking like that okay but I want some
proof that this young man is a diligent
hard-working young man and that he
didn't lose his job because he was
smoking so much reefer he couldn't crawl
to work mm-hmm I really want to know
that before he marries you because I
want you to have a good life so I I want
you to know that you know that you know
that he's marrying you for you not for
an option at citizenship I want you to
know that you know that you know that
this young man is a diligent
hard-working young man who's going to
serve and love his wife well by working
his fanny off once he gets here and that
he has a track record of doing that not
just promises and you have a language
barrier and a culture barrier to figure
all this out in this is the whole
process is fraught with danger it can
work and it might be okay and I might be
just being paranoid I do have the gift
of cynicism but but I'm just this is
what I heard in a short conversation and
so did 16 million people listening to
this conversation they're all going
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
because I wasn't the only one that got
scared when you start talking about this
so you got a language barrier a culture
barrier and a couple of con situations
that you may need to make sure are not
cons before you go forward if this is a
stellar young man and he is all that he
claims to be and he comes here and works
his tail off for the good of his family
and his wife you will be just fine I am
not worried about your debt at all you
will work your way through that I hope
you didn't take that wrong because I did
take my muddy boots and walk off through
your house there but um that's just what
I do just because I care about you and I
want you to win and I don't want to just
drive by this and act like I didn't hear
those thing
because I heard them so you you be good
and I hope this works out please be wise
wise wise wisdom is different than
intellect please get somebody else in
your life to walk with you that looks in
on this from the outside that loves you
and that has wisdom whether it's a dad a
mom a sister a brother and uncle a
pastor I don't care have somebody look
over your shoulder and make sure that
you don't have stars love lovey-dovey
stars in your eyes and you're blind do
that for yourself as a gift to yourself
that's what I would tell you if you were
my own daughter I hope that helps you
well the Dave Ramsey shows changed a
little over the years I just used to
answer questions for my friends now
they're all my kids show for 30 years
you guys all used to be my peers now
with YouTube they're all 22 oh my god oh
well that's what we do here hey I'm
gonna answer the questions here if you
don't want that kind of advice if you
don't want me to tell you what I think
if I were you what would I do in your
shoes don't call because I'm obligated
once you asked and I'm an expert on my
opinion I'm obligated to love you well
try to help you as best I know how some
of you out there might not agree that's
okay get your own show this is mine and
I have to do in good conscience which
causes me to put my head on the pillow
at night and go right to sleep takes me
about 13 seconds